hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago to create my youtube
channel
because i want to show you guys all the
different tools and techniques and i use
that work that work for me
to make money on the markets and most
importantly i want to show you guys
how to use it yourself so if you want to
know about all this stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on fubu tv
let's get into it
[Music]
so very quickly just i want to remind
you what a trader job is we need to
analyze some data and then
we use this data to understand the flows
once we understand the flows we are able
to build up a view and to take our
position
set up our trades technical analysis is
a set of tools that is using
all this information like volumes levels
news
all the stuff and to see how people
react to it so it's
analyzing people's reaction to some news
and some
market situation so i just wanted to
tell you this
before i start to make technical
analysis here because here guys
you know the situation is beautiful and
i was actually telling you guys for a
long time
and you must be surprised how i find out
and
this is why i remind you guys what is
technical analysis is reading the flows
so when i did my video update last week
i was telling you guys that i was seeing
a descending triangle here
on the four hours time frame once again
the four was time frame is the best time
frame to use guys
uh always start from here you know
always start from here
and use the moving averages the macd all
the signals
on this time frame so here i was telling
you we have this descending triangle
and that the the horizontal base is at
20.7
that it is holding for now and that you
know on the longer time frame i was
having uh
same a very strong support at around 20
23 so 21 this area right all this area
so that's why i was bullish and we had
the 200 moving average coming here
so this was the reason why i was bullish
this is why i i i told you guys that we
are waiting for the volumes to kick off
and when they're gonna kick off we're
probably gonna break this and jump side
and that then the same thing will happen
on the you know bigger time frame
so you know we have this breakout here
look at the volume guys the volumes are
insane so
you're gonna tell me yeah but it's not
because we broke it on the upside
that people bought it it's because there
was a news of course guys
of course there is always a news here is
why food tv stock is soaring today
so what happened shares of food tv
popped 12.7
friday guys there was a very bullish day
on thursday as well i did my video on
wednesday
so you know i'm gonna explain what is
happening here but
stay with me so 12.7 friday after the
sports
focus streaming service announced a deal
for the exclusive rights to a major
set of soccer matches so basically
they're gonna live stream the qatar
world cup 2022
qualifying matches of the south american
football confederation
which is very good for them because this
is their business so
guys let me come back to the chart this
was of course on friday
but look what we had on at the close
on thursday all right
close so let's go into hourly time frame
this is the 8th of april
here we are at 20. i did my video here i
was telling you guys this is support
we're going to see some something
happening
and and the last hours we had this very
strong move up around
eight seven or ten percent you know
maybe eight i'm not sure
in a matter of one hour i can measure
this actually
right around ten percent guys or in one
hour so
what happened here some people knew guys
and once again
how did i find out that this level would
work
you know why is the news coming now it's
guys it's because you know the news
they're not coming uh
suddenly at whatever the level is they
are waiting
where it should you know for example on
the 2003 moving average
or at the level where uh you know it's
worth buying this share
and the people who you know control the
use flow
of course you know they give this
information to some friends
to you know some maybe family i i don't
know but i can tell you that there was
some insider that knew that the day
before the news was released
and they both massively and once again
guys
i didn't know there would there was a
news coming but i knew
that something would happen would
trigger some volumes because the level
was
a level where we expect this kind of
stuff to happen
so you know this information was
actually already contained
in the past price action so reading the
past price action
is gonna give you hints of course there
is nothing guaranteed
it's gonna give you hints it's gonna
give you some context
where usually this kind of situations
occur
so this is what actually happened here
right now what can we expect
guys when you have such a big volume day
trading all right so it's the biggest
volumes food tv
ever traded you can see first time they
trade
so many shares in one day what does it
mean it means that it will
keep uh going higher because you never
trade all your shares
in the same day when you need to buy a
lot of shares you're gonna you know this
is not only retail investors this is
institutional clients that are stepping
in in the game which is very good
and they're gonna keep buying it because
this is what they do they have reached
the price
they never do everything the same day
when the size is big and here guys the
size is not big it's huge it's like the
biggest we've never seen
so of course they're going to keep
buying they're going to support the
price
so maybe they're not going to buy any
level but they're going to you know
just buy at the support level that is
around 21
so 21 is not gonna break right now it's
gonna hold
so i think we are done with the bearish
case that will not happen
of course things can change another news
can come so if you see something like
this careful
but i doubt this could happen now that
we have this
big money investors that are buying
food tv so what i expect guys is
actually
you know we have this small triangle
that acted perfectly
that you know have we retested it okay
so you see bam
we have not retested it yet so maybe we
will retest it
you know on tuesday or wednesday i don't
know around
this level so 22 will be acting as
support in the very short term
so i expect something like this maybe
we'll go higher right away but the worst
case we retest it then we go higher
we're probably gonna get here get some
selling reactions
and maybe we're gonna come back to the
20 level i don't believe it i think we
break it and then we finally go higher
all right so this is my preferred
scenario my other scenario is that we
come back here
it takes a bit more more time and then
eventually we break it on the upside
so once again guys this triangle is
converging to the
you know i just connect the two highs
that have here here and here so actually
i have three reactions already
and you know basically end of may mid
may end of may
so this is kind of the longest time it
could take
you know if you want to buy some call
options you know
just think about it take a maturity that
is after uh the 1st of june
and the worst case we have something
like this so guys that's it for me i
hope you enjoyed this video i hope i
managed to explain to you guys what a
trader job
is about about reading the flows
understanding
you know who is doing what how things
work and then
build up a view and set up your trades
so if you did enjoy this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys